our subject for this evening
angels in the classroom
there was a man of the pharisees
named nicodemus
a ruler of the jews
the same came to jesus by night and said
unto him rabbi
we know that thou art a teacher come
from god
for no man can do these miracles that
thou doest
except god be with him
jesus answered and said unto him
verily verily i say unto thee
except a man be born again
he cannot see the kingdom of god
nicodemus saith unto him
how can a man be born when he's old
can he enter the second time into his
mother's womb and be born
jesus answered
verily verily i say unto thee except a
man be born of water and of the spirit
he cannot enter into the kingdom of god
that which is born of the flesh is flesh
and that which is born of the spirit is
spirit
marvel not that i said unto thee ye must
be born again
the wind bleweth where it listeth and
now here is the sound thereof but can't
not tell whence it cometh or whether it
goeth
so is everyone
that is born of the spirit
i thank god again for this glorious
privilege he's given me
to fellowship with you
and to do my best to deliver unto you
the words of life
thus saith the lord
i thank god for this honor and i will
try as best as i can
to make the message as simple as i
possibly can simplicity has power i'm
grateful again to pastor pio for
allowing me to fellowship with his
people and my good elder ammon for being
the contact person thank you very much
my brothers may the lord continue to
bless your leadership of his flock whom
he purchased with his own blood
and for those listening who may not be
seventh the avengers
we are always honored to have you
wherever you are the long arm of god's
goodness can reach you and at the end of
that arm are blessings blessings beyond
your expectation may the lord pull those
blessings upon you and double the
blessings upon your children
thank you very much for joining us let
me remind you we meet tomorrow night
that's thursday then in person at the
church in the dallas fort worth area
our subject for this evening
angels in the classroom
before i begin as always i appeal to you
and i hope my appeal is successful
preserve reverence where you are
you're probably most of you in the
comfort of your homes as i am
preserve reverence and god will be
pleased he deserves our reference
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth
one of the difficulties that face a
preacher is that the preacher is aware
that he's a sinner or she's a sinner so
you've got a sinner preaching to sinners
but god has no one else to preach the
message he will not send angels he has
to use people made of clay such as i and
other preachers and so it's essential
that you pray for the preacher
that god will direct that person's mind
and that person's mouth save number
three
think
it's more a favor to you than to me
isaiah 1 18 come now
let us reason together said the lord
let's borrow heads now and pray
our father and our god we come to you in
the name of jesus christ our savior your
son
the one who created heaven and earth
we ask you immediately dear god if we
sinned against you
forgive us
cleanse us i pray father that we may
understand the messages from above that
you have for us
father i present to you all those
listening right now wherever they are
i ask you to bless them their god with
your presence bless them with the
reformation of truth because it is truth
that sanctifies it is truth that makes
people free
i pray particularly for those who are
not seven they haven't just bless them
where they are father reveal your love
to them in such a way that they will
never forget and that revelation of your
love will draw them close to your bosom
and doubly bless their lovely children
their god for those who are sick with
covet 19
father i ask every night
heal them by god
heal them completely
for your glory
and for them to have a reason to praise
your most deserving name
bless every country represented by those
who listening particularly the host
country of the united states let your
spirit guide the minds of the leaders
that in the deliberations and
power may die for your glory father i
humble myself before you use me i pray
to god as you see fit
in jesus name i pray
amen
angels in the classroom
there are three words that are generally
used to describe what it means to be
divine or to be god
and the three words are
omniscience knowing everything
omnipresence being everywhere at the
same time
and omnipotent having all power and
those indeed apply to god
god is all-powerful omnipotent he's all
present he's everywhere present
omnipresent and he is all-knowing he's
omniscient
which means and these three words only
apply to god
they do not apply to created beings and
i speak with great respect when i say
including angels
and if or if if omniscience does not
apply to angels and god made mankind
lower than the angels surely it does not
apply to us
particularly in our fallen condition it
did not apply to adam in a sinless state
it surely cannot apply to us who have
inherited thousands of years of sin on
this corrupt earth
all knowledge omniscience only applies
to father son
and holy ghost
now having said that
there are things the angels do not
understand
and they learn
and they learn and they learn
obviously the same thing applies to us
now
the bible tells us in
hebrews 11 3
through faith we understand
that the worlds were framed by the word
of god
through
faith
now faith is higher than seeing
hearing smelling tasting or touching
faith
is a spiritual sense
that comes only from god
and it allows us to gain
knowledge above and beyond what we
gained from our five senses
and so the bible says
through faith we understand and this
faith is a gift from god that the worlds
were framed by the word of god to
appreciate creation
we must approach it through faith in the
creator
now the scientific method as used on
this earth
people want to understand first
then they'll have faith god says no no
no no
faith first
and that faith will be the foundation
stone for an ever increasing
understanding god does not function the
way mankind functions the lord does not
see
as we see the lord does not think the
way we think god's thoughts are not our
thoughts his ways are not our ways his
way is
faith
is the foundation stone
ever increasing understanding
the secular approach is understand first
through the exercise of science then
we'll have faith but you and i we i
believe all of us are of the other
school the school that god sets up faith
leading to understanding now
that's for humanity
let us go to first peter chapter one
we'll read from verse nine let's look at
the angels now and see what it is they
desire what is one of their wishes
first peter chapter one reading from
verse nine our subject angels in the
classroom and we've said only god knows
everything angels and mankind do not
know everything they have to learn
verse nine
of first peter one
receiving the end of your faith
even the salvation of your soul the word
and there means the outcome what is that
faith leading to
your salvation so receiving the end of
your faith even the salvation of your
souls
of which salvation the prophets has
inquired and searched diligently who
prophesied of the grace that should come
unto you now first tense tell 10 tells
us the prophets who wrote isaiah malachi
joel jonah you name me
they yearn to understand what they were
writing
verse 11
introduced a very interesting concept we
know from 10
that they wanted searching what auroman
they wanted to understand what you're
writing verse 11 searching what or what
manner of time the spirit of christ
which was in them did signify when it
testified beforehand the sufferings of
christ and the glory that should be
revealed the glory that shall follow
they wanted to understand these two
things the sufferings of christ and all
that entails and the glory that should
follow those the two things now
verse 12 listen carefully
unto whom it was revealed unto the
prophets who wanted to understand the
sufferings of christ and the glory that
should follow verse 12 unto whom it was
revealed
that not unto themselves but unto us
they did minister the things which are
now reported unto you by them that have
preached the gospel unto you with the
holy ghost sent down from heaven listen
to how verse 12 ends which things
the angels desire to look into
one of the things
the sufferings of christ and the glory
that should follow verse 10
and verse 11 the prophets wanted to
understand in other words the plan of
salvation that they wanted to be alive
when christ came because they knew he
was coming they understood that much
they would love to have lived at the
time when jesus christ actually walked
this earth because they understood in
christ it was actually the mighty god
walking this earth they wanted to
understand those things and verse 12
tells us the last part the angels desire
to look into those things now the greek
for look
means to stoop down and get a close look
to examine closely by stooping down it's
the same greek word used in john chapter
20 verse 5 when it says and peter came
and stooping down he looked in he stood
down to look into the tomb to see if
christ was really gone it's the same
greek word and so the angels the picture
we get is the angel bowing lord trying
to understand this thing called the plan
of salvation
but that symbol that picture comes from
the sanctuary and my subject is angels
in the classroom
let us go now to exodus 25 we'll read
from verse 8.
exodus 25 reading from verse 8 let me
pray again
father in heaven as i continue to talk
to your beloved people
make me father a yielded submitted
instrument of communication in your hand
in jesus name i pray amen
exodus 25 verse 8 we know very well let
them make me a sanctuary
that i might dwell among them
then god told tell
moses in verse 10 and they shall make an
ark of wood
cubits and a half shall be the length
thereof and the cubit and a half the
breath thereof and the cubit and i have
the height thereof
and thou shall overlay with pure gold
within and without shalt thou overlay
and i shall make upon it a ground a
crown of gold round about god is giving
moses instructions for the construction
of the ark the sacred ark the most
sacred article of furniture in the
entire system which contained the ten
commandments
now
we go to verse 17
and thou shalt make a mercy seat of pure
gold
two cubers and a half shall be the
length thereof and the cuban and i have
the breath thereof now the mercy seat
was the covering for the ark
and i shall make two childrens of gold
of beaten work shall thou make them in
the two ends of the mercy seat and make
one cherub on the one end and the other
chair on the other end even of the mercy
shall thou make the cherubs in the two
ends thereof listen to verse 20
and the cherubim shall stretch forth
they had their wings on high
covering the mercy seat with their wings
keep reading carefully and their faces
shall look one toward another
now they're not looking at each other as
usual you'll discover
and they face this shallow one toward
another
eagle even toward the mercy seat shall
the faces of the cherubims be or no in
other words they are facing each other
they are not looking at each other they
are looking down
and what's down
the mercy
covering the law
so we have
justice
and mercy we have law
and grace
which sums up or these two expressions
sum up the gospel
law
and grace
law requires the death of the sinner
grace made a way out through jesus
christ we have law and grace and the
angels reason why they are constructed
as they were with their faces looking
down at the mercy sheet it symbolizes
the interest in the plan of salvation
and they desire to understand it is from
this that peter writes in 1st peter
chapter 1 verse 12 which things the
angels desire to look into and so angels
are students
who learn and learn even as we learn
because only god knows everything now
listen to this quotation from the desire
of ages page 19 paragraph two the desire
of ages page 19 paragraph two
by coming to dwell with us with mankind
jesus was to reveal god
both to men
and to angels
by coming to dwell with us
jesus was to reveal god
of the father both to men
and to angels
when christ died on the cross the angels
saw an expression of god's love they
have never ever seen
so they learn something more of the love
of god
when they saw what satan did to christ
on the cross and in his life they learn
something about the true nature of satan
and understanding they did not
completely have angels are in the
classroom they are learning
go to ephesians chapter 3
let's read verses 9
and 10 are subject angels in the
classroom and by the way angels and
mankind are in the classroom but the
angels are ahead of us
ephesians 3
9 and 10 our subject angels of the
classroom and to make all men see
what is the fellowship of the mystery
which from the beginning of the world
had been hidden god who created all
things by jesus christ and to the intent
that now unto the principalities and
powers in heavenly places might be known
by the church
the manifold wisdom of god what the
verse is saying the angels and even
inhabitants on unfallen world they learn
more and more of the gospel and how it
works as they see it working in the
church
this is the verse 10 again
to the intent that now
unto the principalities and powers in
heavenly places beings that inhabit the
heavens holy beings might be known
by the church as god works through the
church
they learn things about salvation
angels do not know
everything but they know a lot
we know even less now why did i go
through all of that to bring us to this
point there's now
a third where i am i have some time
why did i go through that long
presentation introduction to make this
point
let's go to genesis chapter 1
and we read verse 1.
genesis 1
verse 1
in the beginning
gog created the heaven and the earth
what is a human being to make of that
does god have to prove that to me
the answer is no
god does not set out to prove he's the
creator he just states that he's the
creator
god does not set out to prove one thing
or the other he the bible just states
you know when people do research and
they write their papers maybe there's a
recent scientist listening they usually
say research suggests
research indicates
research does this
and research does that now they write
that way because someone else may
conduct other research and disprove that
point and so frequently it is research
suggests god doesn't suggest anything
god declares god states
god declares
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth now what is to be our
response to that
the response god wants
is faith
the only way
to interact with something our senses
cannot grasp alone and unaided the only
way to interact with a reality with
knowledge that our normal five senses
channel grass is by face
i don't see the angels need saving faith
i'm talking about us
god has desired
that we will understand this creation we
will understand salvation we will
understand anything that has to do with
the workings of heaven on this earth we
will understand by
faith faith begins by taking god for who
he is hebrews 11 6 he that cometh to god
must believe that he is
first and that he's a rewarder of them
that diligently seek him
faith
is the way god has designed and devised
that you and i will understand him will
understand the way he works we'll
understand his word we'll understand
creation material and spiritual it is
only through the avenue of faith
because we're dealing with
knowledge
that surpasses that extends far beyond
the capacity of a human being to
understand
so god has given us a means by coming
into by to a means to understand his
word and who he is to some degree and
that means
is
faith
and so the bible says
but without faith
it is impossible to please him
for he that cometh unto god must believe
that he is
and that he's a rewarder of them that
diligently seek him remove faith and
creation makes no sense
remove faith and we will worship
creation instead of the creator remove
faith and we will disown or will deny
the presence of the source of all life
remove faith and people will worship
satan instead of god
without faith
it is
impossible to please god
let's look at the first powerful
expression
of faith
as recorded in the bible chronologically
we know from hebrews 11 verse 5 through
by faith abel offered unto the god more
excellent sacrifice but let's look at
abraham that's what i mean by the first
powerful because he's the one used by
paul whenever he discusses righteousness
by faith and god is the god of abraham
isaac and jacob
not the god of abel seth and shem even
though he was the gods but he's the god
of abraham isaac jacob let's look at
abraham
genesis 15 let's read verse one we're
looking at faith
remember what we read in hebrews 11 6
but he he that cometh unto him
must believe
that he is
then he's a rewarder all right genesis
15 ready for verse 1
and after this and
god
appeared abraham in the vision and said
fear not abraham i am thy shield i that
exceeded great reward
that's right after abraham won a battle
in chapter 14 and took none of the loot
none of the booty
so the word of the lord came unto
abraham in vision saying fear not
abraham i am thy shield and thy
exceeding great reward and abram said
lord
what will thou give me seeing i go
childless and the steward of my house is
this elias of the masses and abram said
behold to me that has given no seed and
lo one born in my house is mine air and
behold the word of the lord came at him
saying this shall not be thine air but
he that shall come forth out of thine
own bowels shall design air
and he brought him forth abroad and said
look now toward heaven and tell the
stars if thou be able to number them
and he said unto him
so shall thy seed be
now abraham looks up and sees all these
stars he can't number
abraham is aware his wife cannot have
children abraham now is listening to
what is in his human mind an
impossibility
god says
that's how many seed you will have like
the stars you cannot count verse 6 says
and he believed in the lord
now abraham was not called upon
to explain how that will happen
all that happened was god said
you will have seed like the stars of the
heaven and elsewhere like the sand on
the seashore abraham believed what he
could not explain abraham believed that
for which he had no scientific
explanation
how can a barren woman have children as
numerous as the stars of the heaven
abraham did not get into all of that all
he knew was who said it
god said it
because god said it abraham believed god
as hebrews 7 6 he that cometh to him to
god must believe that he is and he's
rewarded abraham believed god and god
rewarded him with isaac and after isaac
he had six more sons with his second
wife keturah by the way hagar was not a
recognized wife otherwise said the only
legitimate lawful wife of abraham
was sarah when sarah died he married
katura genesis 25 had six boys with her
abraham ended up with eight sons
he believed in god
let me
tell you what just came to my mind
the only way
to believe in god
is to believe his word
and the only reason why we believe the
word
it's because we believe in god now you
may say what is that circle of reasoning
no
you cannot separate god
from his word
faith in god
is faith in his word
there is no other way
faith in god
is faith in his word because romans 10
17 tells us saints cometh by hearing and
hearing by the word of god when the
bible says in the beginning god created
the heaven and earth verse 2 says and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters and god said let
there be light and there was light one
of my favorite verses and god said we're
instructed immediately that all of the
universe was made by the word of god
not just the word the word of god it has
to be the word of god
faith
is faith in the word of god and of
course the new testament says jesus
calls himself the word it is impossible
to believe in the word and not believe
in god you cannot believe in god and not
believe in the word abraham believed in
god
genesis 15 6 he believed in the lord how
by believing what god had said
they are
inseparable
one way to look at the righteousness of
god is the fact that he is always
faithful to his word i mean
always
as a matter of fact psalm 138 verse 2
tells us god has magnified his word
above all his name
god's reputation for faithfulness is
based on the fact that he always keeps
his word wherever you travel in the
universe whatever you see came into
existence by the word of god faith is
taking god at his word taking god at his
word is taking god
you cannot take the word of god and
leave god taking god at his word is
actually taking god to receive the word
is to receive god
faith therefore is the method by which
we understand god we understand creation
we understand to some degree spiritual
creation at the beginning of the
presentation i recited john
3 1-8 listen to verse 8 as we continue
angels in the classroom
the wind bleweth spiritlessness
and now here is the sound thereof but
can't not tell whence it cometh or
whether it goeth so is everyone that is
born of the spirit christ uses nature he
uses an aspect of creation to explain
something spiritual whether it's a
physical creation or spiritual we do not
understand we have to accept it by faith
and so jesus said nobody fully
understand how conversion takes place
but we believe in the word of god
without faith
it is impossible to please god
if faith pleases god what does doubt do
to god i ask again if faith pleases god
what does doubt do
doubt displeases god i'm not saying when
you and i doubt because all people go
through periods of doubt
we ought not to remain in that doubt in
prison john the baptist sent two
disciples to ask christ are you really
the messiah now john the baptist
baptized christ himself and in john 1 29
he told the audience behold the lamb of
god which taketh away the sins of the
world that's the man said john now he's
in prison now he's about to lose his
head through decapitation his faith
wavers for a while and he wants
reassurance and so occasional doubt is
not that's that's that's not sin
so john said ask him if israeli and
jesus said don't tell john all the
miracles you see
but doubt is not god's will for us god's
will for us is absolute faith a faith
that will not fail though opposed by
many of four as the beautiful himself
angels in the classroom
they have to learn about the plan of
salvation
but we are in the classroom with them
and we learn
by faith by faith our knowledge of god
grows
in ii peter chapter 1
add your faith at your faith virtue
and to virtue knowledge and to knowledge
temperance
so we have knowledge we have faith we
have temperance
faith grows as knowledge grows
let me say it again
faith grows
as knowledge grows let's take another
look at faith and then i'll close the
message angels in the classroom matthew
8 reading from verse 5 let me pray again
father continue to tell me what to say
how to say it and when and bless your
listeners with all kinds of
comprehension in jesus name i pray amen
when jesus came into capernaum
they came unto him a centurion
beseeching him and saying lord
my servant lies at home sick of the
palsy and grievously tormented reading
from matthew 8 we're in verse 6 now
jesus said unto him verse 7 i will come
and heal him
the centurion answered lord i am not
worthy that thou shalt come unto my roof
but speak the word only
and my servant
shall be healed
the power to heal
is the power of god let me go further
the healing power is actually the life
of god
without the life of god no one can be
healed of a sickness a believer or an
atheist without the life of god
no one can experience healing whether
there's healing from a migraine or
healing from covet 19 or healing from
whatever it is the life of god that
brings healing in anyone who is healed
believable or unbelievable that tells
you immediately not as merciful because
a lot of unbelievers experience healings
of all kinds
the centurion answered him lord i am not
worthy that thou shalt come under my
roof verse 8 of matthew 8 but speak the
word only and my servant shall be healed
for i am a man under authority having
servants under me and i say to this one
born again to another comedy cometh unto
my servant do this and he does it he had
soldiers unto him and they obeyed his
command because when he spoke he spoke
with the authority of the emperor of
rome
the centurion understood that christ
would speak with the authority
of the father christ in his humanity
would speak with the authority of the
father
when jesus heard that verse then the
bible says
he marveled
and said to them that followed i have
not found so grossly great faith no not
in israel what was that great faith the
centurion believed in the power of the
word of god
in other words he took god at his word
and he told christ just
saying
the same power in let there be light was
the same power that would heal the
centurion circle
face
and jesus
congratulated the centurion a non-jew
and unbeliever for his faith
it is through faith
that we understand creation physically
that we understand creation spiritual
which is the new birth conversion
justification by faith sanctification
growth in christ all of that is
understood through this heaven-send gift
called
faith
and we live in a world
surrounded by evidence of the power of
god's word a word we can trust because
creation was brought about by the word
of god
and so by way of review
no created being understands everything
not angels not mankind
angels learn
as a matter of fact in uh thoughts from
the mountain blessing page 109 paragraph
two a very fascinating statement
thought from the mount of blessing page
109 paragraph 2 ella white writes these
words
when satan rebelled against the law of
god
the thought that there was a law
came to the angels
almost as an awakening to something and
thought of in other words they
almost had no clue there was a law
they found out
they learned there's a law why they
obeyed god from the heart
it was natural
it's like telling a mother who just
gave birth to a little son and she has
the sun and she's breastfeeding the sun
and you know there's a law in the state
of michigan or texas that you must feed
she doesn't care she doesn't know that
there's something in her that leads her
to fresh feed that little child
he angels naturally from the heart they
obeyed god and so elohim said when satan
rebelled against the law of god the
thought that there was a law came to the
angels almost as an awakening to
something unfortunate they were not
aware that there was a law
god is aware of everything
so that's another evidence that angels
are limited in the understanding but
they're very powerful being very wise
because god sent an angel to explain
daniel to to the visions to daniel god
sent an angel to john so both could
understand what they were writing
angels learn about god
and as we read in the czar of 80s page
19 paragraph 2 by coming to dwell with
us
jesus was to reveal god both to men and
to angels angels learn something about
the love of god as we do
in the classroom our angels
in the classroom are mankind is mankind
angels in the classroom learning but for
us who in the classroom with them our
tool of of learning is
faith
and our faith must be in god
and our faith in god is our faith in
this word because they cannot be
separated so when the bible says
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
that is the word of god and god calls
for you and me to have faith in that
word because that word is the word of
god by having faith in that word we
demonstrate our faith in god when the
bible says thou shalt not steal we have
faith in that word and will respond
based on that faith
by the way he or she who has faith in
the word of god with sin to remember the
sabbath day that person will begin to
start observing or will begin observing
the several sabbath with all the help
god to give
because we proceed
by faith
this world
is a classroom for angels
they don't sit physically but they
observe and they learn but we are also
in a classroom by the way we shall be in
a classroom forever learning learning
learning of the love of god this thing
called the plan of salvation which is so
deep so broad so high so thick and so
dense
but for now
our tool of learning
is faith
my brothers and sisters
you can trust
god's word
let me say it again
you can trust god's word
to doubt the word is the doubt god
to question the word is the question god
to throw as persons on the word is to
throw aspersions on god you can trust
god's word when the bible says bring you
all the tithe into the storehouse that
they may be meet in my house and prove
me now herewith said a lot of hosts if i
will not open you the windows of heaven
and pour you out the blessing that there
shall not be room enough to receive it
you can trust that word that word will
come to pass as it is spoken because it
has as much power as let there be light
and there was light because that is the
word of god and god's word is god
himself
jesus says i'm the truth jesus says i'm
the word in revelation 19 13 and he was
clothed with a vesture dipped in blood
and his name is called the word of god
jesus is truth john 14 says he is the
word and the word was made flesh and
brought among us when you believe the
word you believe christ you believe god
when you receive the word you receive
god as a matter of fact
bizarre of 80 space 67 paragraph one
element writes
it to the word
that christ dwells in his followers
tonight
you and i are in a classroom
of this life
we learn
by faith in the word
angels are also studying because they
don't know everything but god has chosen
for us that we learned through this
thing called faith
that's how we understand some degree the
universe that's how we understand how a
plant functions that's how we understand
the connection between physical creation
and spiritual creation and that's how we
understand to some degree an ever
increasing degree this thing called
salvation which includes justification
sanctification glorification and even
before that it includes the search
christ conducts to find the sinner the
son of man has come the secret to saying
salvation includes the seeking the
finding the justifying the sanctifying
and the glorifying
and we learned that
by faith
and so i say to you my brothers and
sisters faith cometh ou
by hearing
and hearing by the word of god and the
central teaching of the bible is
righteousness by faith it has to be
faith because no one can fully
understand how god
can turn someone who naturally hates him
into a follower that is a mystery
it is righteousness it is justification
by faith we cannot explain it we accept
it as abraham accepted that his barren
wife would have children as numerous as
the stars of heaven we accept it why
because of who said it and god says he
can change your life
and your heart also will i give you and
a new spirit will i put within you
ezekiel 36 26 and in 27 he says i will
cause you to walk in my statutes god is
the power that enables you and me to
obey he will do that
he calls upon us
believe that word
exercise faith if all the faith you have
is as big as this
use it
if your faith is the side of a bathtub
if it's the side of a teacup
use
all god wants is we use the faith he has
given to us to exercise in him
angels in the classroom
people in the classroom and we're
learning about god
we're learning about creation we're
learning about spiritual creation the
plan of salvation and we learn through
faith
in the word
and that word
is christ
i ask you in the name of jesus
accept the word of god as you read as
you study receive it into you for in so
doing in the way i cannot explain you
will be receiving christ into you and
when christ is in you satan has no
chance let me say it again when christ
is in you satan can harass you here ask
jesus but he has no chance of conquering
you when christ is in you no one can put
a spell on you when crisis in you no one
can put dust around your house or
whatever people do go to witch doctors
and have that bother you it cannot
happen why because the god of heaven and
earth dwells in you through the
indwelling of his spirit-filled word and
that happens by constant faith in god
the seventh day is the sabbath believe
it
obey it
return the tithe believe it
obey that call whatever god tells you
ask him for strength
to obey it and the strength to obey is
the presence of god himself in your life
let us pray father in heaven we thank
you for your word
we thank you thank god
that there's a way to learn and learn
and learn and that is by constant faith
in what is revealed
because as we believe what is revealed
you reveal more to us you reward our
faith with greater knowledge and
revelation
father in heaven
we thank you for being the creator
we thank you through christ for being
the savior
we thank you for your undying love dear
god
we thank you that there's room in your
bosom for all of us
where we've doubted you forgive us thank
god forgive and forget father and give
us a brand new chance right now to walk
with you again clasping your hand and
being determined not to release it bless
everyone who listen father a double
blessing on the children and all our
guests
heal the sick they god guide the
governments represented by those
listening father particularly the
government of the host nation bless the
host church i pray bless pastor opio
giving wisdom that you gave to solomon
that he may lead that church forward in
that word bless elder i'm on all the
other leaders there god bring us back
tomorrow to hear your word again we pray
in jesus name
amen